Roberto bolaño was one of the great
novelists of world literature in the
20th century my name is seth bocalee and
i am the co adapter and co-director of
2666 Roberto bolaño was born in Santiago
Chile
in 1953 the son of Leon Vallejo a truck
driver and some time amateur boxer and
Victoria Alvaro a schoolteacher skinny
and nearsighted
he was often bullied at school and in
spite of his dyslexia he developed a
love of books particularly poetry as a
teenager he moved with his family to
Mexico City where he dropped out of
school this was the end of his formal
education in Mexico well Anja found work
as a journalist became involved in
left-wing politics and continued his
self education through the sometimes
random a method of shoplifting books his
taste in literature encompass everything
from jorge luis borges to mark twain
herman melville to philip k dick the
good thing about stealing books equipped
in an interview with argentinian author
Bonica
marie stain is that unlike safes one can
carefully examine their contents before
perpetrating the crime in 1973 Bolano
returned to Chile to support the
embattled regime of Salvador Allende the
world's first democratically elected
marxist president in the wake of I and
his murder bol ano was arrested in
jailed and nearly joined thousands of
others who were imprisoned killed or
sent into exile
instead in an incident he later wrote
about he was spotted and released by two
former classmates now working as prison
guards or at least that is the believed
a sequence of events as with a number of
stories about milania's life more than
one version exists and there are many
contested facts by 1975 palana was back
in Mexico where he co-founded in fur
really small a surrealist influenced
anti status quo poetry movement
by 1977 the movement had fizzled and
Bolano left Mexico for Europe eventually
finding his way to Spain where he would
spend the rest of his life he worked as
a dishwasher a bellhop a costume jewelry
salesman garbage collector and a night
watchman at a campground low-paying but
intellectually uncompromising jobs that
allowed him to write often fatherhood
drove Melania to shift from poetry to
fiction he felt responsible for the
future financial well-being of his
family and thought it would be easier to
earn a living writing fiction spurred on
by both his need to provide and by his
failing health
he was already suffering from the
effects of the liver disease that would
eventually claim his life he wrote a
series of compact potent novellas which
gained him some critical acclaim but it
was the 1998 publication of the savage
detectives that cemented his growing
reputation as one of the most important
new voices in Latin American literature
2666 was the book that consumed the
final years of Roberto bolaños life and
it was published after his death from
liver failure at the age of 50 in
writing this five-part epic melania
pulled from his own chaotic history to
create a stimulating thrilling
disturbing and global portrait of the
modern world and the artists role within
it the artists characters in 2666 are
marginalized driven to poverty and in
some cases madness by their commitment
to their art but like Bologna
they are also truth tellers rebels
willing to stand up to the corrupting
forces of power and money in Bolanos
mythology poets are beings who have
nothing to lose 2666 is clearly Bolanos
great imperfect torrential work blazing
a path into the unknown
milania's novel like our adaptation
proposes fewer answers than it does
questions or mysteries but perhaps as
one of the characters says the secret of
the world is hidden
experience Roberto bolaños 2666
performances start February 6 go to
Goodman Theatre org for more information
you